somebody
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right now this article uh I pulled
up because I'm not gonna say I totally
agree or discreet I'm gonna be neutral
as a host oh [ __ ] that give me yes
I'm gonna be I'm playing a neutral
unbiased perspective as a host however I
gotta admit I gotta admit the title was
very catchy for a group of men to sit
here and discuss yeah oh no don't give
up you already don't get us canceled
let's talk about abortion
new research suggests women are more
likely to cheat than men in a
relationship
dang women are more likely to cheat oh
but what's consent let's define terms is
cheating [ __ ] is it emotionally
cheating is it like what is considered
cheating I know why because they got
three holes no no this is what happened
this is what happened we all know
cheating comes the with the amount of
availability that's why it's like
celebrities and [ __ ] they said no
they're not any worse of any other human
being they just have more availability
more chances to cheat they're just
taking more so what happened was
dating apps right dating apps really
Quantified what we all knew somewhere in
the back of our [ __ ] minds but now
it's real the girl in jail is like oh
there's a thousand guys ready to take me
out if you're like a bad chick semi bad
chick even a five out of a ten I always
tell friends like you miss your girl
dating app don't look at that phone
because there's literally 1200 guys
waiting to take her out to at any given
time and now they know it for real so
anytime you [ __ ] up on a girl it's like
part of them are like well I have like
1200 dudes ready to take me out like
tonight and there's guys that'll just
say yes even without knowing what the
girl looks like [ __ ] it they're willing
on that picture they don't even [ __ ]
know we all just swipe yeah I got I got
the guys be like you exist like I got a
40 meal for you 100 I got a 40 meal for
you girls in La don't even they don't
even [ __ ] pay for food anymore for
like a year they're like I'm not paying
for food anymore yeah that's true I
don't I don't have any budget in my
budget for food anymore I have any
budget in my budget my budget is my my
money budget there's no more there's no
more food in my money budget
my money budget I'm not budgeting for
food anymore every night there's a free
dinner if they want it that's pretty
sweet yeah that's a good deal that's why
they're more likely
like my eyes you know you have to be
some badass guys wish they could cheat
more than women yeah well we're all just
desperate losers I know guys have to try
what I mean by that is I love you
blankets he's got a point don't pursue I
love blankets if you don't pursue and
you're just a guy that's sitting around
and if you're not a top like dude where
where pussy's being thrown at you're not
a top G right so like most guys don't
have girls sliding into their DMS here's
a free [ __ ] tit most guys
that's that's how they slide it hello
there's a free tit [ __ ] titty right
most dudes are the dudes at the [ __ ]
Redondo Beach pier you got 40 [ __ ]
fishing lines over waiting for 12 hours
ain't nothing bite exactly first of all
I do that the reality is we all think as
men that we choose our girls you know we
went after our girl but the reality is
God chooses for us they don't chooses us
we you can only choose the girls that
have already chosen us yeah we can't
even [ __ ] go to the girl that's
[ __ ] unless she's like yeah come talk
to me so we only get to choose out of
the ones that are choosing us when most
girls can kind of choose whatever the
[ __ ] they want very true
what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] damn it yeah
I'm not paying for food no more in Ellen
I got no money but if you're a chick in
L.A and you don't eat sugar fresh every
night it's cause you stupid
it could be eating sugar you could eat
the nozawa special every night it's
crazy but it's true though it is true I
know my homies now who have been on
dating ass for like a couple years you
know what I mean that like if things
didn't work out you know sometimes
people just we've all been there yeah
sort of
um but now they're like you know what
no no more expensive dinner dates every
first two days is coffee only yep huh
I've heard that because they've been on
so many dates they get an eight dollar
[ __ ] what but what if they're
hungry what if I am that's why they set
it up because we're gonna meet we gotta
meet up a coffee because those those
dudes are like looking for love it's
different but then that girl like
cancels like I can't meet at 3 30 can we
just meet like 5 36.
it's like coffee days like now we gotta
eat dinner no cause I know we get coffee
because it's like you know it's gonna
curb your appetite you ain't gonna be
hungry right
so it's it's basically new research
again neutral host over here okay that's
true how neutral are you you already got
the research so new super neutral while
the common school of thought is that men
tend to stray first apparently a wealth
of new Research indicates that women May
struggle more than men with monogamy
okay Anthropologist and author of quote
untrue
it's untrue this person's name is
Wednesday Martin said the late Wednesday
to check by the way and what's untrue
from from some writing from untrue
that's a bad title yeah it's confusing
confusing it's an untrue title
said the latest research on female
libido indicates that contrary to
popular belief the female sex drive is
alive and well and wants more happy so
popular belief says that the men's
libido is [ __ ] gangster T-Rex [ __ ]
and the funeral libido is like a mini
little teddy bear right if you look at a
[ __ ] long enough it Winks at you that's
meant that's men writing that history
for long goddamn time it's true so the
new research is correcting false Notions
that women have lesser libidos that
women are more naturally monogamous and
that it's easier for women to partner
for life okay that's only Penguins
women don't like sex less but they do
get bored of sexual sameness since the
research oh that's interesting streaming
for her book on female infidelity Martin
interviewed dozens of sociologists sex
researchers and anthropologists to get
the bottom of get to the bottom of the
feminine sex drive Martin found that men
may experience higher levels of
spontaneous desire but women take the
lead when it comes to responding to what
is called triggered desire spontaneous
desires when you suddenly think it would
be nice to have sex it comes over you
like hunger or thirst that's so true
that's that's so true what's it called
again spontaneous spontaneous desire is
it spontaneous if it happens every day
yeah just spontaneous [ __ ] curry rice
and I'm like I need a doggy style a girl
right now doggy style somebody
you're just [ __ ] eating a chicken
cuts of Curry and you're just like and
there's no correlation you know it would
be nice right now doggy stop reverse
cowgirl will be why does that happen
you're just like oh what floor I need to
get on uh I think I'm on the 11th floor
her and then you go man I need to pull
down her [ __ ] skirt and [ __ ] her yeah
you're like I wonder if we can [ __ ]
fit there's no one in the elevator in
the elevator
no one's in the elevator that's the best
part Sarah Casey you're like we could
buy [ __ ] right here the staircase no
one's coming down this staircase in the
next few
whereas responsive or triggered desire
occurs when something suggests the idea
of sex to you you're watching or reading
something or a partner initiates a
sexual encounter and you get turned on
wow so that is stronger apparently in
the females in the women oh just men
we're a little spontaneous combustion
men don't need it men don't need a
reason to be pushing the elevator button
and like I need a [ __ ] [ __ ] women
want we need to be coached women might
need to like they might be seeing some
gas and they might take the gas in the
hole they'll like pump it a few times
and they're like it's a pun I need to
try to drill oh [ __ ] I'm horny you know
that's different George is going to be
eating katsu I might be doing [ __ ]
karate I'm at a competition I'm trying
to win a [ __ ] black belt and [ __ ] and
then I turn around and I'm gonna like
tonight I need a [ __ ] instant black
belt
what I think is happening is this [ __ ] I
don't know I think it's gearing us up to
realize that women are coming as like
and coming in the world where it's like
this is the most equal we've been
probably in society for like many so for
the first time we're like they have
libido too well it's finally like people
women talking like hold up [ __ ]
like because this just hundreds of
thousands of years of men saying no
these [ __ ] are kind of libidos
they're just following us and now like
not the women that are now coming to
power and their voices mean more than
ever before saying this is actually how
it is you idiots
it's like Victoria medicine where it's
like this [ __ ] is gonna [ __ ] have a
she's gonna faint you know remember that
they used to say hot take though yeah I
love this
for everything a man says is a woman
that says actually
exactly I mean just just sip in a Red
Bull like
we're in the time of actually I think
right yeah this is a calm before the
stormy I feel like if all men agreed to
this another woman's gonna come out and
go actually yeah you're like this is not
true they hate when we agree though the
way they get turned on is clearly
different or I'll still be way more
strip clubs
you know what I mean like for women so
like the way that guys get turned on is
like we just need to see body oh
absolutely this is like any time anytime
like you know a lady like just happens
to need to shower and I just see some
coverage I'm not [ __ ] it's easy right
yeah I might be like flashing my penis
and she's like um it's a different it's
a different not the same the easiest way
to tell is just by the market otherwise
there would be an equally profitable
only fans of men exactly but there's
none and only for the gay crowd before
Playboy did yeah it's very true research
by Missouri State University nobody ever
played you bought Playgirl
now I get I got hooked up they put me on
their like Ambassador I get free
magazines were you guys use this promo
they still do magazines hell no so and
for your your butt ass naked Airborne
magazine photo shoot oh yeah oh yeah
dude world famous airport magazine like
I said research by Missouri State
University looked at women using the
Ashley Madison website which I don't
know what the [ __ ] that is is that the
cheating one yes to cheat on their
Partners which I don't know what the
[ __ ] that is yeah so it says it
throughout the notion
throughout the notion that women cheat
only when they are unhappy in their
relationships and seek an emotional
connection instead of sexual sexual
that's true because I think guys could
love the [ __ ] out of their wives and
still want to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of other
girls
is that true Anthony
I'm neutral
be wait before you move on we need to
know what's the question
that you love the
other chicks do you believe that men can
love a woman and still [ __ ] another
woman without damaging the love they
have for this woman
[Laughter]
quote the women's study went on the site
created a profile vetted candidates met
them in person and quote auditioned them
this was a very intentional process
Martin said they wanted to find partners
for sex she added they reported being in
sexless or orgasm-less marriages and
they simply wanted what they couldn't
get at home because it's affection these
Affairs were a way for them to remain in
their primary relationships which
probably also adds to the fact that I
would assume consistent monogamous
sexual relationships are still more or
less guys climaxing and girls not all
the time is that is that really the
truth guys I think there's I think it's
it's there's intimacy and love and
affection and all those things that
they're talking about it's not just
orgasm like that's just a physical thing
but these chicks are frustrated it
sounds like they can't get but it's
probably because they don't love them in
my opinion I think it's because they
can't just that's true it's like they
have to have the whole connection like I
feel on unfulfilled too there's the
we're the we're in an era of savage like
there's an attitude the new girl the new
generation of girls on that Savage [ __ ]
and the the dating apps and being when I
was single again I got in the clubs and
I was like oh
okay women
are on their man [ __ ] like they ain't
[ __ ] around they run the world ever
since girls trip came out dude Marvin's
like to be honest part of the thing
about you saying the play go play with
things I think it can some of it could
be a attributed to Norms of the society
at times I mean if we looked at porn
right now online porn I'd like to see
who's watching porn women we see that
now you may see a more equal thing of
like how many girls are watching porn
and how many guys are watching porn then
you're like okay well then now
everything it might be more equal how
many guys how many girls but how many
guys are watching like 10 000 hours to
girls one yeah yeah what explains the
top the top only fans creators being
girls you know what yeah yeah
no for sure because they're big because
guys are visually stimulated where's the
male representation on that charger it's
also it's also male only fans are gay
because the it's guys buying them
because it's God's life